the whole
the
time
uh
huh
is
right
uh
yeah can happen
um
muslims
here we go
hi everyone
good afternoon as part of our
administration's efforts to increase
transparency and introduce all of you to
the policy experts who are leading the
president's initiatives
we're joined today by domestic policy
advisor susan rice
who will be talking about the racial
equity executive order that the
president will be signing
this afternoon she's kindly offered to
stick around and take some questions i
will as usual play the role of bad cop
when it's time for her to go so with
that i'll turn it over to susan
good afternoon everyone it's good to be
back
jen thanks the president has committed
the whole of our government to advancing
racial justice and equity for all
americans
i'm leading this effort out of the
domestic policy council
i've assembled a first-rate team to
drive this agenda forward
will hold the federal government
accountable for advancing equity for
families
across america i have the support of
every white house office and every
agency in this work
because as president biden has made
clear advancing equity
is everybody's job tackling these
challenges though is personal for me
i'm the descendant of immigrants from
jamaica and
enslaved americans my grandparents and
my parents are beneficiaries of the
american dream
and so am i my family's story is a
remarkable one of the march towards
greater equality
and opportunity but for too many
american families
systemic racism and inequality in our
economy
laws and institutions still put the
american dream
far out of reach today the average black
family has just one-tenth
the wealth of the average white family
while the gap between the white and
black between white and black
in home ownership is now larger than it
was
in nineteen sixty these long-standing
inequities are compounded
by the converging crises we face as a
nation
americans of color are being infected by
and dying from cobit 19
at higher rates one in 10 black
americans and one in 11 latino workers
are currently unemployed by some
estimates
40 percent of black-owned businesses
have been forced to close for good
during the covid crisis
black and latino families with children
are twice as likely to be experiencing
food insecurity
during the pandemic as white families
and black and latino americans are 2.8
times more likely
to die of covet 19.
and for native communities across the
country
the overlapping economic and health
crises
have devastated tribal economies and
health care systems
these are desperate times for so many
americans
and all americans need urgent federal
action
to meet this moment today president
biden will deliver
a national address on his plans to
advance racial justice
and equity starting with an equitable
and inclusive recovery president biden
will renew
the federal government's commitment to
making the american dream
real for families across the nation by
taking ambitious steps to redress
inequality in our economy and expand
opportunity for communities that have
been left behind
including communities of color his
economic plans make historic
make historic investments in underserved
communities
and put equity at the heart of our
recovery
his ambitious agenda builds on a legacy
of americans
forging opportunity out of crisis these
aren't
feel good policies the evidence is clear
investing in equity is good for economic
growth
and it creates jobs for all americans
economists have estimated that the us
economy has lost
a staggering 16 trillion dollars
over the last 20 years because of
discrimination
against families of color if we closed
racial gaps
in income and opportunity these same
economists have estimated we could add
five trillion dollars to the u.s economy
over the next five years and add over
six million
new jobs for all americans
so building a more equitable economy is
essential
if americans are going to compete and
thrive
in the 21st century we've hit the ground
running
to embed equity throughout the
administration on day one the president
signed an executive order
directing an unprecedented whole of
government initiative
to embed racial equity across federal
policies programs
and institutions that starts with a
review
of policies and institutions to redress
systemic racism
where it exists and to advance equity
where we aren't doing
enough every agency will place equity
at the core of their public engagement
their policy design and program delivery
to ensure that government resources are
reaching americans
of color and all marginalized
communities
rural urban disabled lgbtq plus
religious minorities and so many others
the president has put equity at the
center of his response to the covet 19
and economic crises his executive orders
signed last week
deliver rent relief student debt
reprieve
and emergency food assistance to
families across the country
helping all americans including black
and brown families who we know are being
hit
hardest by this crisis and he took steps
to make our broken immigration system
more humane
and secure he restored the integrity of
the census
so that our constitutionally mandated
accounting of
every person in the united states is
fair
and inclusive and even before taking
office president biden released his
american rescue plan
that will make historic investments in
advancing equity
independent economists estimate that his
plan will cut child
poverty in half cut
child poverty in half for all americans
and reduce over all poverty
by 30 black american families this year
will face a poverty rate of 20 percent
if congress does not act on the american
rescue plan
but if enacted the poverty rate
would fall by over one-third and it'd
fall by 40 percent for latino families
and by
one-fifth for american for
asian-american and pacific islander
families
the american rescue plan also provides
critical relief to native american
communities
and tribes these investments will lift
over 8 million
black latino and asian americans out of
poverty
and provide relief across sectors where
families of color are most
disproportionately impacted by this
crisis in food and financial security
health care access
and education and child care today
president biden is continuing his
commitment
to embedding equity at the center of his
agenda
by signing an additional package of
executive actions
president will sign a memorandum
directing the department of housing and
urban development
to mitigate racial bias in housing and
affirmatively advance our nation's
fair housing laws he will also sign an
executive order directing the department
of justice
not to renew any contracts with private
prisons
private prisons profiteer off of federal
prisoners and are proven to be
or found to be by the department of
justice inspector general
to be less safe for correctional
officers and for prisoners
president biden is committed to reducing
mass incarceration
while making our communities safer that
starts with ending the federal
government's reliance
on private prisons the president will
also sign an executive order
reinvigorating the commitment of all
federal agencies
to engage in regular robust and
meaningful consultation
with tribal governments and the
president will sign a memorandum
directing all federal agencies to take
steps to combat
xenophobia and acts of violence against
asian americans and pacific islanders
who have been targeted by political
leaders uh in our nation's response to
covet 19.
again these are continuation of our
initial steps to advance racial justice
and equity
through early executive action beyond
this
the president is committed to working
with congress to advance equity in our
economy our criminal justice systems our
health care systems
and in our schools as i've said many
times
in my personal capacity and i say again
i believe
we all rise or fall together
advancing equity is a critical part of
healing
and of restoring unity in our nation
the president will have more to say
about all of this later this afternoon
and i'm happy to take a few of your
questions peter
ambassador thank you um you speak about
communities of color right now that are
disproportionately impacted
by the pandemic of course they're also
less inclined to have faith in the
federal government response the
vaccination process
so what specifically i'll follow up with
others but what specifically
is being done right now for communities
of color to convince them it's okay to
get this vaccine
well peter i will leave much of this to
my colleague jeff science who's leading
our covered response but i think
two important points one uh we have
established within our covet task force
an effort on equity uh and and that
includes
obviously racial equity um that will
focus
in on health disparities but also on the
reality that there are
americans who uh and particularly
americans of color
um who for very valid historical reasons
are skeptical uh and reluctant um and
a large part of what our colleagues on
the covet task force are doing this is
the second part
um is reaching out directly through
targeted campaigns
to get to those very communities where
the skepticism is highest
and that's vitally important because as
we as
communities of color are suffering
disproportionately
i may have less access to information
about the vaccine
uh and the ability to easily go online
in some instances and and get an
appointment
we have to take those additional steps
to ensure that they are aware of its
availability
they can get appointments uh and that
they understand that the vaccine is safe
i have a couple things one's news a day
but another one there's a lot of day one
promises right now
news of the day okay fine let me ask you
all
on february 20th of last year president
biden said my first day of office i'm
going to send a bill to the congress
repealing the liability protection for
gundy manufacturers
closing the background check loopholes
and waiting period so what happened to
that day one promise
well uh i think you've seen that we have
rolled out an unprecedented number
uh of early executive actions and as
you've heard jen say and many of my
colleagues say this is just the
beginning
we have fourteen hundred and fifty four
more days left
in uh president biden's first term uh
and so give us a little something to do
over the next few days
certainly thank you investor a
housekeeping question if
if i may and then a follow-up um can you
speak specifically to what this
does as it relates to immigration and
immigrants
does this cover particularly the prisons
and private prisons housing immigrants
undocumented immigrants tens of
thousands of whom are facing deportation
in privately run prisons right now
this uh order today applies to the
department of justice run prisons it is
not
uh in this instance applicable uh to
those run by other agencies
not ice not anything like that okay and
then and then going back to january 6
and what we saw just a few weeks ago at
the capitol when we saw people
roaming that building carrying
confederate flags wearing anti-semitic
shirts we saw lawmakers in that group we
saw firefighters in that group we saw
military veterans in that group
what are you doing to address this issue
of white nationalism
and how concerned are you about the
threat of
from some of these groups leading into
this impeachment trial
i think we have seen and it's been
plain for all americans on their
television sets just how
serious a problem uh we face from
nationalists and white supremacists who
uh uh have demonstrated willingness to
resort to violence
in some instances um and that is why
um the president has ordered
the intelligence community to compile a
comprehensive
assessment of the nature of this threat
and challenge and its
origins and roots and thus
provide policymakers with inputs it
would be very important to
address this challenge the national
security council
has uh set up a capacity within
the nsc to focus on dives domestic
violent extremism
uh and to ensure that uh we are
within the white house and within the
interagency uh
coordinating efforts to to to craft and
implement policies that will address
this so we're taking it quite seriously
and why doesn't this address the ice
private detentions
uh it addresses the department of
justice prisons
in the first instance it's not it's
silent on what may or may not
transpire with ice facilities
there was a department of justice uh in
inspector general report in 2016
uh that underscored that um
private prisons in the in the un funded
by doj were
less safe less secure and arguably less
humane
this was the
obama biden administration took steps to
end
renewing of of contracts for uh private
prisons trump administration
uh reversed that and we're
re-establishing it
go ahead i know we met this morning
mario parker bloomberg news thank you
ambassador rice
two questions uh the first what will the
administration do to
address the relationship between
communities of color and police
particularly as part of the mass
incarcerate incarceration component
and then second question republican
legislatures have signaled that they're
going to look to roll back
some of the voting procedures from the
last election
uh we know that that's centered in some
of those swing states and
largely black and brown communities
what's the administration going to do
about that as well
well with respect to a prison's policing
uh
the entire basket of very important
criminal justice reform
issues this is something that we are
committed to addressing and we will have
more to say on criminal justice in the
coming weeks
including on matters related to uh
policing
uh so please stay tuned for that um with
respect to efforts to roll back the
access to the ballot
this is something that uh i expected the
president will address in his remarks
today
it's a matter of real concern because
uh we ought to be in the business of
encouraging and enabling all americans
who are eligible to vote
to be able to vote um and that's why you
know we will
continue to work with congress
on its various efforts to advance
democratic reforms there's legislation
on the hill
that would move us in that direction
including
restoring and revitalizing the voting
rights act jonathan you'll have to be
the last one but susan will come back
i'm sure you're gonna want to come back
we'll welcome you
thank you ambassador these measures here
executive actions which of course
could be overturned and reversed by a
future president
can you talk about what steps could be
taken to codify these to
make to make them permanent whether it's
private prisons or other measures so
they could not be
undone by a future president as you know
to codify something and and make it
lasting in law requires
uh that congress uh both houses of
congress pass it and that the president
sign it
um and for this as well as many other
things
there will be areas where legislative
actions are the the best and and most
durable approach
there'll be some instances where in
advance of legislation or
efforts to achieve legislation uh it's
wise to take it back
executive action so i don't think we
should assume
that by doing something by executive
action
uh and where it may also be appropriate
uh to seek legislation that we wouldn't
do it
um we have a very full legislative
agenda the president's first priority is
uh enacting the american rescue plan
as well as getting our nominees
confirmed and
we'll be focused in the next few weeks
on that thank you ambassador rice
thank you jen thank you everybody
okay uh just a couple more things at the
top and then
be happy to take your questions
uh the president and his team have been
working around the clock
over the past six days to make
meaningful progress on vaccinating as
many people as possible
as we've talked about in this room
before increasing the vaccine supply
and building increased cooperation
between the federal government and state
and local leaders on the ground
is key to getting that done the
president will speak later today
on those efforts and provide an update
on his team's work to bolster
the vaccine supply available so that we
can in turn get more shots into
americans arms
as quickly as possible and i'll also add
as as many of you have reported
there are some calls this afternoon with
governors to brief them on these plans
and give them an update on how we will
continue to
uh work work together even more
efficiently
um a couple other things earlier today
the first female
vice president swore in the first female
secretary of the treasury
uh what's that for history um dr janet
yellen
today of course is a pretty historic day
and this afternoon the vice president
will make her first visit
to a federal agency the national
institutes of health
where she she and the second second
gentleman excuse me will receive their
second dosed of the moderna
vaccine the vice president will thank
director collins dr
felci and the staff of the nih for their
work to develop the vaccine
and efforts to keep americans safe she
will also make the case that congress
needs to immediately pass the american
rescue plan
which includes 20 billion dollars to
invest in local community vaccine
distribution centers
in the hardest hit areas her remarks and
the vaccination at nih will be live
streams on the white house
youtube channel so you can all turn in
tune in for all of that
uh okay jonathan kick us off uh thank
you jen uh
first on the response to the pandemic
two matters there
uh first but you give us to provide us a
little more details to how much more
of the uh vaccine is going to be
distributed and how quickly
uh to these states we've heard governor
sound the alarm that they are
desperately low and what they need
and then could you talk about a cdc
considered the white house support
a measure for testing for all pastors on
u.s
domestic flights uh well jonathan on the
first
part of our effort is certainly to
ensure we are
more effectively and efficiently working
with governors and local
officials who have expressed some
frustration in recent weeks about
the lack of information and the lack of
a federal plan
we've only been here six days but we
want to take steps as quickly as
possible to
address that and part of that will be
what the president updates us all on
this afternoon and
i would be a very short-lived press
secretary if i got ahead of the
president and we're having so much fun
in here so you don't want that to happen
uh on the second question on testing
we're constantly evaluating of course
our medical and health experts
steps that need to be taken to keep the
american people safe we announced
some travel restrictions as you know uh
yesterday
i don't have any additional restrictions
to preview or announce for all of you
i will remind you that tomorrow is the
first day of our uh
briefings that will be happening
approximately three times a week that
you can all
tune in and learn more from our health
experts on our plans
and on another matter on impeachment the
president yesterday in an interview
said that he did not believe that former
president trump would be convicted and
therefore
removed from office but said he felt
like it had to go the trial had to go on
anyway could you please explain what he
meant by that
sure well let's put this in context of
last night so last night the
house impeachment managers delivered the
articles of impeachment to the senate
with a dramatic walk
over as we you all carried on television
uh
and um you know the president was
referencing the
fact that he referenced in his statement
of just a couple of weeks ago when the
house passed
uh the impeachment the article's
impeachment themselves which is that now
it of course will move on
to the senate as he also said at the
time um
he hopes and i'll quote him here the
senate leadership will find a way to
deal with their constitutional
responsibilities on impeachment while
also working on the other urgent
business
of the nation he still continues to feel
that way so
last night they delivered the articles
the next step as you all have reported
and people watching at home know
is for the senate to proceed with their
trial he's going to allow them to move
forward at the pace
and manner that the leaders in the
senate determine
uh and i can promise you that we will
leave the vote counting
to leaders in the senate from now on
uh on this the why is why is the
president so reluctant to express his
personal opinion as to what happens here
we understand he's not the senate
anymore
but he is the leader of the democratic
party why won't he say what he believes
should have
well the president believes that the
senate has the constitutional duty
to proceed as they see fit on holding
the former president accountable
he spent 36 years in the senate he's no
longer there
as the president of the united states he
feels his role is to deliver on
what he promised for the american people
so that's what he's trying to do every
day
uh go ahead peter just a little
housekeeping as it relates to
what's going on in the senate right now
when is the last time that president
biden spoke to leader mcconnell
uh he has spoken with leader mcconnell
as he said it's spoken with him a couple
of times uh
but i'm not gonna i i'm not gonna read
out specific calls to all of you on on
the pace or number of their phone calls
i guess the question is this is someone
who has always said
the president that his strong suit is
the ability to work with both sides of
the aisle
and he criticized the previous
administration for not bringing
lawmakers here on covet relief to sit
down in the oval office
so why not say to democrats and
republicans come to the white house
right now let's hash this out let's get
it done
well i know that would make for
excellent television um and quite a
dramatic moment here at the white house
uh but
he is in close touch as our team is
members of our senior team as you know
brian diese
a number of senior officials here at the
white house speaking with different
caucuses in congress republicans
democrats people from different wings of
different parties about
our plans and our commitment to getting
the covid
package passed um but uh our just
our view is that a lot of those
conversations should happen one-on-one
should happen in small groups
and that's the most productive way to
move this bill forward let me ask if i
can there seemed to be a little bit of
disagreement in terms of the way both dr
fausti and president biden viewed herd
immunity and when we get out of this
pandemic right now we heard the
president yesterday say i feel confident
that by summer we're gonna be well on
our way
towards herd immunity dr fauci said that
he thought this would likely occur
or we were closer to being back to
normal by this fall just so it's clear
for americans what
the administration is promising or
telling them when should we expect that
takes place
well the president is certainly pushing
his team every day
uh to deliver uh results as quickly as
possible
so as part of his comments yesterday he
also talked about his uh
desire to ensure there's greater
availability in the spring
and certainly has hope uh that every
american will
uh that more americans will have access
as quickly as possible um but he has
also said many times it will take months
and months
for a broad swath of the population to
be vaccinated um
and as always he's guided as we all are
by
scientists and medical experts and
certainly uh dr fauci's guidelines of
when we can expect
uh for a broad swath of the population
to be vaccinated for specificity on the
vaccine stockpile yesterday
you didn't have a specific number cdc
director um
rachelle velensky didn't as well what is
the stockpile
right now where do we stand at this
moment well the president is going to
have
more of an update later this afternoon
as i uh as i
um previewed earlier do we now do we
have our hands around that
well certainly there is a uh we
monitor updates on a daily basis through
tiberius um
and multiple systems that have available
information on
vaccine numbers that are distributed to
states uh what states have received what
they have distributed
and we've been connecting all the dots
to ensure we have a
our best understanding of where the
holdups are and uh we of course have
that assessment but we're continuing to
dig in
every day and where the whole what the
issues are why aren't why isn't the
vaccine getting out to states what is
the holdup with vaccinators why aren't
there more vaccine sites that are
getting
the destruct the supply they need but
later this afternoon
uh he'll have more of an update on uh
our uh additional vaccine uh supply that
we'll make available to states
go ahead peter thank you peter pete and
pete
uh poor pete and repeat i guess so the
jokes could go on
okay go ahead yeah let's do that um so
there are some reports that fema is now
planning to reroute
up to 10 billion dollars of money that
could be used
to combat cobia 19 right now to
preemptively combat climate
change by building uh sea walls and
elevating
flood-prone homes and i'm curious if
there has been any thought given to
waiting until covet is behind us to do
that
uh peter i had not actually seen that
report before we came out here as you
know and i'll just repeat
the president's first priority is
getting the pandemic under control and
doing everything needed putting all the
necessary resources behind that but
i'm happy to circle back with our team
on that specific report and
another question uh the president says
that he hopes
that the senate leadership can continue
uh
can do an impeachment trial while
working on the people's business
what if they can't well as as president
you always have to be hopeful of course
that's your role as a leader to push and
push leaders push
democrats and republicans to make more
progress but
you know i think what the president will
continue to do privately in his
conversations with members of congress
democrats and republicans and publicly
is make the case for the cost of an
action
uh and i think he doesn't feel that
their
the democrats and republicans in
congress uh have the the space and the
time to wait
um that there's an urgency that the
american people are going to continue
to push members who are representing
them on
and so i don't think he feels there's an
alternative other than
them to move forward with urgency just
one more the
riots in portland and the violence in
portland recently
there was some discussion earlier about
the january 6th rioters being reviewed
by the dni
as domestic violent extremists are the
rioters in portland
also being viewed through the same lens
or is that something different
that's the white house i think we you
and i talked about this yesterday
and conveyed that uh all violence
happening around the country will be
reviewed as a part of the
uh the tasking that was done by the
national security team but i don't have
anything to preview on it cecilia
on copic relief um we've heard
republicans come out in opposition
in broad brush strokes at this point but
in terms of the conversations that
uh right he's having or the president
for that matter or anyone on your team
has any republican come forward to give
you an alternative
what what is happening with these
negotiations what are they telling you
that they want to go
to stay what's the none without you
negotiating from here but
what alternatives are they giving you
well cecilia you have the benefit of
having covered congress
for quite some time and you know none of
them are quiet about what they like and
don't like and they often say it
publicly so
uh the president and members of our team
are hearing
many of the same uh you know expressions
of support and sometimes
expressions of questions about whether
packages need the package needs to be
the same size whether it's targeted
whether it should be targeted in this
way those are the same questions that
they are
hearing privately and uh but what they
all what the president is also hearing
privately and what members of our team
is
are also hearing privately is that uh
they expect him to be focused
on this package and they will be as well
and they hear and understand the urgency
um and as you know from covering this
quite for quite some time yourself
oftentimes things come together right
before there's a vote right the
president kind of alluded to this
yesterday
but we feel democracy is working how it
should he laid out his big package his
big vision of what it should look like
and people are giving their feedback and
he's happy to have those discussions
and fully expects it's not going to look
exactly the same on the other end
assessment i want to flip the answer
that you've been giving saying that it's
five days or six days
give us some time to catch up with this
i understand that
on the inverse it's been six days
why don't we know exactly what is in
this stockpile how
what have been the hurdles the biggest
hurdles in getting that answer
slowly you probably heard this uh
yesterday defended the program operation
warp speed saying that this is the
results were
exceptional so why is it taking so long
six six days in well six days in the
president is also giving an update on
steps we're going to take to provide
more vaccine supply to states across the
country
in response to their concern there has
not been a federal plan in place and
that they haven't received the
coordination cooperation and information
they desired so
in my view that's a pretty rapid
response to states concerns
we do have an assessment as i reference
tiberius which is quite a name for this
website i will say um
sounds like a magical creature a little
bit to me but um
it provides vaccine information publicly
available information on
vaccine supply that's gone to states and
what's been used it doesn't mean it's
perfect
oftentimes it isn't but our our concerns
and our focus is not just on the supply
that's part of the issue
it is also about uh ensuring that states
have the number of vaccinators they need
so that means
people who are literally taking the
shots and qualified to put them in the
arms of americans um
and some states and some communities
don't have people who
are able to do that and vaccine centers
and places where people can go
and receive the vaccine so there's
multiple steps in this process
and our focus is ensuring ensuring
not just the supply is at the rate it
needs to be and that states have
more advanced notice this is one of the
things governors will tell you and have
told us
that it is very difficult for them when
they find out a day before a couple days
before that they're going to run out of
supply or when a next supply
shipment is coming they want more time
that's something we're also working on
so those are all pieces that are part of
this herculean operational task
that our team has undertaken go ahead
mario
thanks jen uh senator schumer last night
said that he wants president biden to
consider declaring climate change
a national emergency to give him power
similar to what his predecessor
president trump did with the wall
is that something that the the president
is considering
well the president has long said it is
one of the four crises
that he believes are central to the
presidency and central to his time
as the commander-in-chief and the
president of the united states
addressing
the threat of climate so he has not only
taken actions executive
orders taken actions that uh fall under
the purview of the president but also
he is pushed to find ways to work with
congress on taking additional steps
moving forward too
there'll be more we have uh to share on
our efforts on climate in the days ahead
but
uh i don't think uh leader schumer uh
has a any doubt about the president's
commitment to this and
and certainly the fact that he has
called it a crisis it is he said it is
central to
the issues he wants to take on his
presidency speaks to his commitment to
the issue
go ahead so two more questions to bring
it back just to cover response for a
second
so first um one of the questions that's
come up is
is how much money is needed exactly to
respond to the emergency that we're in
is it 1.9 trillion is it some other
figure um
do you have an assessment just of how
much money is left from congress's
last allocation towards these issues
yeah how much is left to spend well as
brian d's nec director brian z said last
week um the the problem with focusing on
the 900 billion dollar package is the
answer to our current problem now
is that was is catching up for what had
not been done for the prior six months
so what we're really focused on now is
what is needed
for immediately now of course but also
in the months ahead and as i was
alluding to a little bit earlier
the way the president thinks about this
is what the cost of an action is
so if you look ahead it's critical and i
talked about this a little bit yesterday
that we don't get anywhere near the
march cliff which would mean the end of
eviction and foreclosure moratoriums the
end of 300
additional ui assistance the end of pp
ppp loan applications for small
businesses and as you all know from
covering what's happening in the country
you know people need security and what
we're trying to do
now is provide that so this package was
designed not with a number in mind we
weren't trying to get a shock value
sticker value
we the president relied on the advice of
economists of health experts and others
who who recommended this is the size
and the the the components that are
needed now
not just to distribute the vaccine but
to provide certainty and a bridge to the
american people to get to the other side
so right now for how much is for vaccine
distribution alone how much you have to
spend
uh as compared to what you've asked for
i'm happy to check with our team on that
but
i will say that what we're looking ahead
to is where are we in a couple of weeks
and where are we in two months and no
one wants to be having a conversation in
may about why our schools aren't open
and why millions of people have been
kicked off of unemployment insurance so
part of our role here is to look ahead
and that's what exactly what we're
trying to do with this package
it's one of one other issue um the
president
trump signed an executive order
restricting
exports of vaccines that are
manufactured within the united states
that order is still in effect um first
of all what is your
assessment of exactly uh
whether uh drug manufacturers are able
to
send these vaccines overseas can they do
that under current law
um and two will you take any action to
reverse that executive order
uh that's a great question and we've
talked about obviously joining rejoining
the world health organization and
ensuring we are
a partner to the global community on
this effort only makes
us safer and america the american people
safer but i'd have to check on the
specific export question for you go
ahead
uh jen the national copa strategy the
administration
released just a couple days ago says
that the united states will accelerate
the pace
of vaccinations by encouraging states
and localities to move
through priority groups more quickly
what is more quickly how should
governors interpret that
and uh and you know will you provide
more detailed guidance to
state and public health officials on how
they should be going through these
priority groups
well the answer is yes and part of our
effort as i mentioned there was a call
with governors this afternoon to
provide an update on vaccine supply and
steps we're taking from the federal
government to ensure they have
not just the information they need but
also the access to supply they need
and in terms of the pace the guidelines
will of course be
um publicized by the cdc they have their
first briefing tomorrow we'll see if
they have an update on that
but really what they're trying to what
we're all trying to
uh endeavor to do is ensure that we have
not just more supply
but more vaccinators as i noted more
people in communities who can vaccinate
more centers and locations that can
provide these vaccinations so all of
those components will lead to expediting
we're not asking states to do this on
their own in fact we're
asking where we're trying to reset and
be partners here in a more effective way
than we've seen over the last 10 months
health officials seem to be recommending
now double masking is that something
that the white house would like to see
i've seen some of those reports i
haven't seen that come officially from
the cdc
um but again i'd encourage you to ask
them that question tomorrow and
i'd refer to them for any new guidance
on that front go ahead
hi regarding the defense production act
what is the timeline for ram they have
production and supplies specifically
specialized syringes and has the
administration been in talks with any
specific companies or manufacturers
it's already been invoked and underway
so those discussions and efforts to ramp
up production are already underway
uh they started as of 20 less than 24
hours after the president
signed that executive order and made
that announcement last week i don't have
any
specific companies i don't think to kind
of preview or read out for you but
i'm sure we can follow up and see if
there's more specifics to
to provide on the specific companies
department of defense considering
uh plans to deploy military national
guard to help
with the vaccinations be those
vaccinators and communities that are
underserved
well certainly um the government across
the government uh
everyone is going to play a role in
covid and addressing covenant and
getting the pandemic under control but
in terms of their specific
plans i would send you to the department
of defense on behalf of the radio pool
sure the administration's this is for a
reporter who can't be in the room
what are the administration's plans for
guantanamo and
restarting uh military trials for
detainees
one case announced last week i don't
have any on that for you as well
go ahead um i just wanted to circle back
to peter's question
uh so dr fauci on fox today went back
supporting that
100 million doses of 100 days number
so did the president misspeak when he
said the new goal
is 150 million shots in 100 days
yesterday
or was he operating under some new
update that he got
the president didn't actually say the
new goal is the president said
i hope we can do even more than that and
that is certainly of course his hope
he is continuing to push our team
to uh get as many americans vaccinated
as quickly as possible that's why we set
the bold goal
of 100 million shots in the arms of
americans in 100 days to begin with
i would just remind everyone this has
literally never been done before
and as what he has asked the team to do
and what the team is focused on doing
is also planning for contingencies i
mean we're at war with the virus
so in in a wartime theme here
there are a lot of things you plan for
including trucks breaking down freezers
breaking
uh you know needing to plan for that you
know not having
vaccinators in lo a location to be able
to put the syringes in
people's arms 100 million number though
would be a more accurate number
to be cited that's the number we
set based on the recommendations of
health and medical experts continues to
be our goal
but does he want to do beat that goal of
course he does of course he does um
but again it is a goal that was set um
with
uh contingencies we need to plan for in
minds and he's going to continue to push
the team
to uh to meet that goal and go beyond it
go ahead i wanted to ask the ambassador
but i didn't get a chance to which is in
terms of the
racial equity goals does the white house
support
overturning small business
administration language that prohibits
people with records
from accessing ppp relief it's something
that on the hill
has in support of portland and harding i
i know i i had talked a little bit with
our econ economic team about
this issue earlier but i'll have to
circle back with you on it's a good
question we'll bring ambassador rice
back but we'll circle back with you on
this today
yamiche go ahead in the back hi i have a
couple questions versus
david kessler said that most americans
would not be vaccinated until
the third or fourth quarter of this year
he said that last week president biden
spoke and said that he
we could possibly have heard immunity as
early as this summer
that's the difference of a couple months
i wonder if you could reconcile the
difference there and
talk a little bit more about when herd
immunity and most americans will be able
to be vaccinated
well it's sort of similar to what peter
asked a little bit earlier
but you know what the president uh the
president is of course pushing his team
to deliver results
uh and his goal is to ensure there is a
greater availability in the spring and
that it continues to
improve in the summer everybody won't be
uh won't be eligible this spring as you
all know even with
even as cdc the cdc continues to provide
updated
guidance but he would certainly defer to
medical health and medical experts and
obviously the guidance of dr fauci on
when we
may be at the pace of reaching herd
immunity but you know we will continue
to update as
more progress is made what the goals
look like following up on that
in terms of data collection it's my
understanding that
something like 50 of the vaccinations
are coming in without
racial data is that accurate or is that
or is there something else
there i'm wondering how you'll measure
success and
vaccinating people of color and
vulnerable communities if you don't have
the data on who's getting vaccinated and
will we see we've seen kind of mobile
outlooks mobile mobile kind of
mobile um just mobile outreach to those
communities
in terms of vaccines when we see that
yes
absolutely that will be part of it but
also part of it will be
working with pharmacies and working with
health centers in communities so that
communities in across the country rural
communities communities of color
um have uh easier access
to know where they can go and and uh and
get a vaccine
but this is going to be hard and we are
not trying to sugarcoat that and it will
be very challenging this is why
everybody who comes and speaks about
kovid talks about our
the challenge of vaccine hesitancy and
how we're going to overcome that and
it won't just be just about having
centers it will also be about
overcoming a lot of these contingencies
i've mentioned that we have to plan for
about more effectively communicating
with people about the safety of the
vaccine and
really being thoughtful about who we're
using to communicate
so it is it is going to take a
multifaceted approach
and we are uh open-eyed about the
challenge
part of that question is it is it
accurate that there's
very little racial that are at least
less than 50 percent of racial data
coming in on vaccinations
i would i would defer i would uh refer
you to the cdc and i know they'll have
their first briefing tomorrow and and
that sounds like a great question to ask
them
she didn't take all the questions so
maybe i'll ask you the same sure the
question i was going to ask her which is
we've seen after january 6th there
there's obviously this issue of white
supremacy and racism
coursing through our country um what's
the biggest challenge when you think of
equity in this country and how do you
measure success
for something like that especially when
we think of all of the different ways
that our country is dealing with it i
know this
these eos are about housing and about
criminal justice but can you talk a
little bit about how you're going to
measure success
and what the federal government's role
is on something so big is inequality and
racism
well i think what what ambassador rice
was conveying to all of you and
obviously what the president will sign
later this afternoon is an executive
order that
makes racial equity in addressing racial
equity a priority across the government
and what the pres how the president
talks about this
is that far too often we think of racial
issues that are
in the racial equity bucket shall we say
are only related to a couple of
categories and that's just not
accurate um we need to address racial
equity
in terms of health disparity we need to
address it in terms of access to
lending into loans we need to address it
in terms of
biases and discrimination as it relates
to housing and so
what this executive order will do will
make it a priority and infuse
expertise and personnel to ensure we are
addressing issues that impact
communities of color across the country
every day and not just
every few months when uh it's an issue
that uh that comes up and and prompts
questioning
um go ahead in the back thank you jen
and thank you for
making sure that everybody gets the
opportunity to ask questions i really
appreciate that
i've got one on housekeeping real quick
and then i've got a domestic under
foreign policy question
so you got some beautiful screens behind
you um
your predecessors have rejected multiple
requests to bring back the skype c
uh to the daily briefings for the
benefit of reporters who are trying to
stay safe during the pandemic by working
remotely
would you consider bringing back the
skype seat
would i i will say uh people don't
usually realize this but
there's normally about 60 people in this
room i think that's the right number
that's certainly something we would be
happy to have in this room and i think
all of you would too because you're
asking questions on behalf of your
colleagues but we also uh we
we rely on the advice of our health and
medical experts on what's safe not just
for us but for all of you
uh and and having everybody sit seat by
seat wouldn't be safe i know that's not
what you're asking but
we'd certainly be open to taking
questions via skype
we i took some questions on twitter the
other day we're going to try to take
some questions from the american people
that they ask on youtube and so we'll
continue to look for
ways to not just bring back the daily
briefing but to take questions from more
reporters and and people
okay um third thing i'm paying this is
the foreign policy question during the
campaign mr bainet said
that he would give benefit to the
palestinians but he didn't specify
anything that he would ask
any concessions so the question is is it
the belief of this administration
that the palestinians don't have to make
concessions to get
funding or a consulate
well uh i i think i've talked about this
particular issue enough in my old days
at the state department to know i'm
going to
defer to our national security team and
the state department and jake sullivan
on any more specifics obviously the
president's view continues to be that a
two-state solution is the only path
forward and
uh that you know that that continues to
be the position of his uh white house in
advance
finally this on behalf of a colleague
who's not able to be here today they're
doing social discipline
does the president believe he can attain
unity with the 74 million
trump voters while urging his allies in
the senate to hold an impeachment trial
after his predecessor has already left
office well the president's belief is
that he was elected
by 81 million americans uh be
in part because they believed that he
was somebody who could
help bring the country together uh unify
the country around addressing the crisis
that we face
and when he talks every day nearly about
uh getting the pandemic under control
putting people back to work
he's not just speaking to people who
voted for him he's speaking to
all of the american people including the
74 million who didn't vote for him
and certainly addressing the pandemic
making ensuring that people don't worry
about the health and safety of their
grandparents
of their sisters and brothers getting
kids back to school that's not a
partisan position
that's a position that's a leadership
position and one he's taking
uh because he wants to make sure he's
delivering for all the american people
go ahead all the money
the president spoke with chancellor
merkel yesterday
but the readout from the phone call
doesn't mention nordstrom 2 the pipeline
from
russia to germany have they discussed
uh this particular project and what's uh
president biden's position on
nordstrom 2 is he determined to use all
the tools
he has like sanctions to stop the
project
uh well i don't have any more for you on
the particular readout but i can convey
that we continue to believe the
president continues to believe that
nordstrom 2 is a bad deal for europe
we're aware that the previous
administration imposed new restrictions
on activities
related to the pipeline under the
national defense authorization act and
we
we will be reviewing those measures and
so he looks forward to continuing to
consult with our european partners on
this issue and if there's more
to share on his conversation with uh
chancellor merkel on it we will
certainly circle back with you more
directly
let me just get to everybody go ahead
thank you jen this is just following on
from yamici's question earlier we heard
the president yesterday say that
anyone who wanted to get a shot would be
able to get one by spring
and that would be we would be well on
our way to home hurt immunity by summer
i'm wondering how we can make those
projections and we don't know what the
national stockpile is
when the cdc director says that supply
won't increase until march
and when we're still having these
enormous distribution problems in the
different states
well let me first start by saying as i
started the briefing conveying the
president will have more to say
on our vaccine supply and also
and also assistance and cooperation that
we will be doing with the states later
this afternoon so we'll have an update
on that
and as i also noted we do have a sense
there is uh
tiberius my favorite word of the day uh
a website that has
available information on not just the
vaccine that is available in states but
what has been distributed so
what i was conveying and i think what a
number of our medical and health experts
have been conveying is that
we've been here for now six days i'll at
a certain point stop saying that but
less than a week is not that long a
period of time
we are assessing every day where the
holes are where the gaps are what the
hold ups are it's not just supply
it is beyond that it's also having the
number of vaccinators we need the number
of vaccine distribution sites we need
those are all issues if you talk to any
governor that they will say are
challenges
she spoke to this a little bit last week
and i expect
this will be one of the lines of
questioning with our health and medical
experts
when they have their first briefing
tomorrow and they have spoken to both
um assessments that have been made about
the efficacy of the vaccine even with
the new variants
and how they are evaluating um you know
what the efficacy will be moving forward
this is something that they will
continue to look at
through a medical and health lens so i
don't think i'm going to have a new
update or assessment for you
from here but it's something they're
looking closely at and uh the president
will continue to encourage them to be as
honest and straightforward with the
american people as possible
just one unrelated uh question uh
one of the first of president trump's
last acts
was to grant uh protective status to
venezuelans who are in the united states
uh i believe that still stands can you
give us
an update on your position on that sure
let me see
let's see um well the overriding goal
of the united states is to support a
peaceful democratic transition
in venezuela through free and fair
elections
he has long been clear the president
that is that his administration's
approach to venezuela
will focus on addressing the
humanitarian situation providing support
to the venezuelan people
and reinvigorating multilateral
diplomacy to press for a democratic
outcome
and pursue individuals involved in
corruption human rights abuses
and pursue individuals involved with
that
i don't have anything more for you on
the status of temporary protected status
that was a mouthful
um i will of course our national
security team is
uh doing a review of all of the
positions and
put in place by the trump administration
and we'll provide an update when we have
one
go ahead one more question um ambassador
rice
outlined all of these disparities when
it comes to americans of color
being infected and dying from coveted at
higher rates
do you does the white house fault the
policies of the previous administration
for
creating those disparities that we're
seeing
well health disparities in communities
of color
existed long before the trump
administration took office and i think
that's a statement of fact
but what did not happen uh was
actions put in place to ensure greater
accessibility to communication
communities of color for health care
greater
greater communications on public
campaign about how communities of color
could gain access
to health care and treatments
and certainly the actions taken by the
prior administration to
uh for all intensive purposes destroy
the affordable care act
didn't help any american and certainly
didn't help communities of color so
the vaccine as you all know has only uh
we did not have the scientific and
medical breakthrough
until late last year um and now it's
incumbent upon
this administration the biden harris
administration to ensure
that we are taking sex steps to increase
access but also to communicate more
effectively
with communities of color about the
vaccine and the efficacy of it
and that certainly is a primary focus
that's one of the reasons why
dr marcela nunez smith is leading a cova
task force and is a pivotal part of the
covid team and
i will say from being on the transition
she wasn't a person who was
aside from by reputation but she wasn't
known by president
then president-elect biden previously
but he was so impressed with her
as a member of the covid advisory task
force that he felt
personally it was important to have her
as a pivotal member of the team to
address exactly this issue
okay well go ahead last one
says jonathan thank you very much if i
can ask a follow-up i appreciate it
the trump administration granted waivers
to arkansas and other states to require
work for some medicaid recipients
that was challenged in the court court
struck it down the trump
administration pushed it to the supreme
court
its pending there does the bind
administration support these waivers
oppose them
are they going to argue forward against
it what's the position of the
administration
well well i would certainly send you to
our department of justice my department
of justice colleagues to speak to
anything related to a legal case
i will say that president biden does not
believe as a principle it should be
difficult
to uh for people to gain access to
health care and he's not
he's not been supportive in the past and
is not today of putting additional
restrictions in place and he's spoken
about that publicly too
and then if i follow up yesterday former
president
trump endorsed sarah huckabee sanders
for governor of arkansas in 2022
where does president biden stand on that
particular race and how high is this on
his list of priorities
wow how high is the arkansas republican
gubernatorial primary on the president's
list of priorities
not high i can confirm for you i'm not
running for governor of connecticut in
the future
so i'm here to confirm that for you as
well i don't expect he will get involved
in
this race but also politics is not front
and center for his mind in general at
this point in time he's focused on
getting the pandemic under control
okay for clarity
who's making leading the governors the
president won't be on it so who is
leader uh jeff science will be one of
the
uh one of the uh health officials or one
of these i should say policy officials
who's
on the call today there may be others
but he's one of the primary leaders of
the club
obviously i believe so yes exactly okay
last one i'm breaking jonathan's rule
but
the president biden has spoken to
presidents putin can you give a uh give
us an update on the nature of their call
what came up well i bel the call i can
confirm for you the call was scheduled
um
the call has happened i believe since i
have come out here so we will
of course be putting a readout of the
call
out but since you gave me the
opportunity um i will just
convey to you that he called him called
president putin this afternoon with the
intention of discussing
our willingness to extend new start for
five years
and also to reaffirm our
strong support for ukraine's sovereignty
in the face of russians ongoing
russia's ongoing aggression and also to
raise matters of concern including the
solar winds hack
reports of russia placing bounties on
united states soldiers in afghanistan
interference in the 2020 election the
poisoning of alexey navalny and
treatment of peaceful protesters by
russian security forces
uh his intention was also to make clear
that the united states will act firmly
in defense of our national interests in
response to
malign actions by russia but
we'll have a readout for you i assume
sometime early this afternoon thanks
everyone
thank you
you